this video is probably one of the best
depictions of solar Punk it's a future
where we merge future technology with
Ecentric values and we thrive in harmony
with nature the combination of these
words kind of immediately make you think
of a cult and why is that the punk in
both solar Punk and cyber Punk refers to
Rebellion cyber Punk is against an
oppressive techn dystopia and solar Punk
is against consumerism and capitalism
which is leading to the destruction of
the planet the solar is both literal and
metaphorical literally it represents
solar and other renewable energies and
metaphorically it's talking about this
Beacon of light in a dark cyberpunk
world run by corporate interests there
are films and video games out there that
fit the solar Punk aesthetic but they
don't quite fit the true definition of
solar Punk when it comes to the social
or cultural aspects